then the real hollywood came and i'll
tell you what i'll let you in on loose
somebody i'm not gonna drop names okay
but i'll never forget the
these are black producers
uh a guy named kevin brown and andre
brown
uh and he was later on 30 rock but he
they would come to us and they would
tell us about vanity
and losing your mind in hollywood and be
careful and they came back from
hollywood
to try and expand us
and they sat us down like you ain't
gonna believe what we saw
like what what did you see
and they said
we saw so and so huge name
so-and-so
huge name
and so and so
big name back in the day
chicken hawking at a party and i went
what
see you're white i said what's chicken
hawking everyone
he's white he don't know chicken i said
what is chicken hawking that's when you
are hanging out with boys at a
transvestite i went why
why
uh see now now you're telling stories
now you're telling stories yeah
but
i never forgot that
three years later this name ping
busted chicken hawking that one's sick
this one being
busted yeah
huh they swept that uh that's what i
call
to me hollywood's a mafia
it's a big dark mafia yeah it is and
then what happens is i remember one of
them it was like
the mobsters come they're like we
understand not mobs is like a time right
right right whatever you're talking
about
the attorneys yeah right and they come
along like listen you sign this you do
some movies there we'll put the soul on
the table we got enough money make this
go away
paying it's gone no one ever brings it
up
no one ever brings it up with this
person that's crazy and there's two or
three of them huge
huge but
i guess what i'm saying is by the time
i started doing sounded live and i have
baked blah blah
and and tv thing
you know tim allen all this chat it was
that's when i really saw how dark and so
it's just it was dark it's
i get creeped out i get scared to death
it was soulless yeah never seen anything
it and i still every time i get out
there i feel like oh man i just i don't
feel life
out there yeah i feel it at all
you know what i know i've always said
when i get off the plane there i feel
like i'm in the office it always like um
i just feel like i'm in an office
constantly it always every light feels
like a fluorescent light it feels like
it never ends
but it's hard to find a it is it's hard
to find a comfort out there but there's
always this dangle
of a carrot yeah and it's a carrot and i
don't even know what it is because like
it's vanity is vanity
is it
you know you want this right you know
you want this
you're better than so and so you know
you're better than so and so you get
this then it'll be worth this yeah and
then you're and then your road will be
worth this you want to be you think that
person deserves to be in arenas or on
billboards you should be on take you
want it
that i'm thinking i'm trying to feel
like you know a lot of times things will
land for me and my feelings like is it
vanity is it
yeah it's something
it's ego and vanity yeah it's ego it's
vanity i want to be better than them
yeah it's
uh yeah it's uh it's not easy
no it's not easy and i i think also
you start to see the other like
you start to see the other side of it
too where it just
there's never like an understanding you
never get to talk to the person to have
the conversation about what's
it's just there's never any real
instructions it's all kind of vague
the business is vague the money is it's
all it's all vague and there's all extra
people always stacked in at the last
minute you've never met right and they
are they're living and they've owned
your family now they're just crazy your
grandfather is now their grandfather
like it's a non-stop scarface movie yeah
yeah you got it you got the money got
the other seven of you
what just happened we thank you
what's going on they're cutting you
they're they're putting you in a
commercial for bone sauce as they're
cutting you in half you know put this
dress on and then take out your take
your pants off and this is gonna get you
big
time hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one